puis tout moi gauche
[Musique]
the next day en plus dans les sdi
c'est
le contraire
en trente ans parle moi c'est un
traquenard
où
prend note
[Musique]
tout ça
mais ce dont je veux vous interview
aujourd'hui pour une chaîne youtube
savall six camions j'aurais voulu avoir
des petites réponses sur votre dernier
film concernant les armes chimiques
qu'en est il le film s'appelle amchit
sur l'anr et vous devez réaliser les
pointant à la réalité
l'année dernière il a été diffusé sur la
chaîne arte en février après 2014 ce
film traite des arsenaux mondiaux enfoui
sous un verre dans les lacs un peu
partout à nantes qu'elle était l'endroit
le plus pollué que vous avez pu visiter
va du seuil et surtout les armes
chimiques qui ont été j'étais dans les
océans dans les mers
d'autres dossiers du monde et on affine
est partout dans le monde et
3,80 et on peut dire que
lotion ou les mères la plus polluée
c'était la baltique sans doute voulu
avec oi dans la baltique c'était surtout
la gare ou tard quand on l'appelle le
mythe des guérites ibérique voilà et
quel est le risque en fait de cette
tendance cet enfouissement soi mais
quels sont les risques si surtout les
risques sont
les pêcheurs poulets
pour les poissons
épaules on veut vraiment
de la mer tous les journalistes qui sont
là les chercheurs vous allez rencontrer
qui enquêtait sur ce sujet là vous ont
donné un délai un temps critiques
le problème c'est que la plupart des
césars en étais-je été après la seule
dans la gueule il y a déjà raté j'étais
comme ça quand la première guerre
mondiale mais
plupart étaient jetés après la seconde
guerre mondiale et ils ont été éjectés
dans des
bars et des variants des maris en métal
et
c'est d'arriver en une vie à cause de
l'argent à profusion de plus ou moins 50
ans c'est à dire que nous sommes
maintenant vous n'arrivez la période
charnière voilà c est le moment critique
où césar bon
départ ils sont en train de s'ouvrir et
c'est en 1822 est-ce que vous avez
enquêté article sur la manche sur la mer
méditerranée la côte d'azur oui surtout
il y a même si en france sur la côte
d'azur il ya des zones même aujourd'hui
comme on voit des signes où on ne peut
pas se baigner mais ne sais pas pourquoi
il ya un mais c'est à cause de
difficultés gtl là et surtout on n'a pas
filmé en france même imprimer beaucoup
en italie la côte atlantique qui a
vraiment une autre qui est très très peu
à peu la baltique on peut dire que ces
italiens qui invoque au
design chez qui se trouve dans l'océan
atlantique
vous avez rencontré la population est ce
que vous allez discuter avec la
population du risque qui deux ans pour m
la plupart de la population
une sont pas au courant de ce trouble
parce que c'est un sujet très triste
écrit qui a été personne à parler de ça
est vraiment peu dire que ce fils et la
première fois
ah
ça a été discuté
dans publiquement il ya des enquêtes qui
a été fait par des journalistes surtout
en italie à john isner créer un livre il
y a
pas combien d'années mais c'est assez
récemment cinq 5 ans laissez nous vos
sujets et quand on parle à parler avec
des personnes qu'on était en train de
filmer au bord de la mer ce soit dans la
baltique ou soit en italie et en pente
raide et j'en ai demandé qu'est ce que
vous faites dans leur demander est ce
que vous savez qu'il ya des hadjis tout
brownies et très choqué
je pense que la population ne sont pas
au courant et c'est un sujet qui effraie
beaucoup vous avez été choisi pour
réalisateur des réalisateurs de ce
documentaire parce que vous étiez à la
base aussi réalisateur d'un film x apple
en traque soir ce que vous pouvez me
dire deux mots sur ce film là oui le
film m
c'était un type qui valait à la
situation des déchets biologiques
en ce moment les recherches qui se passe
mais les développements des hommes des
logiques est vraiment là c'est ainsi
qu'a démarré après les attaques de
d'un tracks ou juste après le 11
septembre aux états unis des lettres qui
continue d'un track 100 été envoyé à des
médias et à d
goku sénateurs américains à washington
et vous avez enquêté sur les souches
tous et anthrax wimart l'entité c'était
une des choses que nous devons essayer
de garder le souvenir de certains tracts
pour savoir ce qu'on a sous sa venue et
de de faire une investigation quitté
forensic en
est donc qu'est-ce que vous avez
normalement sur ces souches est
aussi en regard du temps après sur une
souche qui est ce qu'on appelle là bas
non mais wayne white knight rises
militarisée et alizée et qui était très
très sophistiqués ce qui a été travaillé
riche beaucoup de moyens et la
conclusion en fait
que c'était
une souche qui était vraiment travailler
que c'est ça devait venir d'un d'un
projet d'état
que c'était pas possible que une
personne ou
même un petit groupe de personnes
puissent
développer il suffit par et vous sortez
grands moyens donc votre avis est-ce que
vous pensez que c'était une façon dont
et avait d'intimité certaines
institutions pour légitimer quelques
lois antiterroristes face propagation
d'armes biologiques on ne peut pas
savoir les réserves nationales mais on
ne va pas spéculer vraiment des mais
c'est sûr que
ce qui est arrivé que ces attaques
d'avancer
[Musique]
beaucoup de nouveaux recherche sur les
armes biologiques et beaucoup de très
grandes dépenses et des grands budgets
qui ont été un
des succès mais on s'est vraiment que
aussi que les armes biologiques on ne
parle pas beaucoup mais que tous les
états sont en train de travailler sur ça
près vous êtes reporter de guerre on
avait fait quelques passages heures
pendant certains conflits comme on vient
de l'époque qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient
déterminé qu'est-ce qu'ils après
destinée à enquêter sur ce type de son
vol d'armes biologiques
pour moi ça venait de gigue en d1 en
afrique
zimbabwe ou au zimbabwe à l'époque
suscité la colonie anglaise de la
rhodésie nous avons vu qu'une guerre
très violente des dépendances et moi
j'ai grandi dans la société
comment j'étais à petit col j'ai grandi
comme nicolas est en jeu c'est d'y aller
lâche soulagement dger la guerre était
en pleine force là et vous coûter les
amis de l'école ont été faits la dia et
moi je n'ai pas fait je me suis jésus
six ans filets
après que je suis journaliste
j'ai su que les forces rhodésienne la
désarmer
la vie du gouvernement doit à utiliser
les hommes
biologique et les armes chimiques
et surtout ils ont utilisés dans
pratiquement vidé pour le zimbabwe a eu
la plus grande épidémie d'un prêtre dans
l'allier
en
qui a tué
plus de 300 personnes infectées plus de
10 me
et c'était je me suis trouvée après
en 2001 à new york juste à l'époque de
la cataracte et je me suis demandé est
ce qu'il ya un lien entre ce qui s'est
passé dans mon pays dit bah ouais et ce
qui se passait aux états unis et c'est
ça qui redémarre une fille lourdes
conséquences
c'est une question qui intéresse pouvoir
respirer il y a un lien à skis dernière
question pour vous bon
quel est le piia conflit que vous avez
été amené à voir vos intérieurs de
l'entente en vigueur
et tous les conflits s'en
sent mauvais s'enterrer la guerre c'est
quelque chose d'affreux
expérience et
mais un peu dit peut-être
les libérer c'était pathétique et leur
moi
de dire un peu fou
à prospecter des jeunes qui étaient des
jeunes gens qui étaient drogués avec les
armes
beaucoup de confusion beaucoup de
désordre beaucoup de danger présentez
nous votre avis je vous présente mon
associé à éric nabeul en à travailler
ensemble les défis archi nique sous la
neige et le film un trac soir on a fait
en sont issus et ça fait dix ans que
nous travaillons ensemble
[Musique]
respectueux par
semaine comme chaque année les
nombreuses au
chili
[Musique]
arsenal c'est
légitimer ce droit oui disent prétexte
fallacieux
technologie heuristique
et
des
poèmes
[Musique]
quand vous avez vu une brute jd en ville
entre à ce qu'il était d autres actions
à l'époque il est maintenant notre avis
c'est un point très important pour
tous qui a été entraîneur de la linguère
shit et c'était très important et dans
le film un tract loin
c'est aussi un point très important
parce que
à travers de chercher l'histoire qu'est
ce qui se passait dans les zones
géologiques conscient en
inquiéter sûrement des chercheurs
plusieurs chercheurs et le plus fameux
c'était délicat qui était celui qui
avait
dit parce que quand on lui parle a pris
7,7 un tract c'était sur des
renseignements qui sont tenues à travers
les anglais les américains et en fait
dire qu'elle est amenée par les pentes
issa et qui avait dit que que le dossier
a été sexta vous avez dit fabriquer et
7 à cause de sa couleur la bbc en fait
un grand scandale parce que il avait dit
ça
en effet chili en dessous
mais la bbc à l'époque on a donné son
nom au lycée louis querbes et 10 ans et
ça prouve et provoqué un très grand
honneur
en angleterre qui a
presque
forcé tremblay a démissionné à cause à
cause de ça et tient en fait
causé la mort d'une façon ou d'une autre
de
dégainer on lundi qui s'est suicidé
quelques jours après que il a été devant
le parlement anglais pour apprendre à
des questions sur le sujet et c'était
celui ci très suspect dans beaucoup des
choses alors
sans doute c'est un moment très
important pour
pour les grandes puissances pour
l'entrée en irak et comme le savons
maintenant en septembre l'irak nous
vivons les conséquences
jusqu'aujourd'hui je vais vous poser une
adaptation depuis l'avant dernière
question par aucune addition nous avons
la chance d'avoir deux américains en
face de la caméra je voudrais avoir
votre perception sur le concept de
guerre contre le terrorisme
de concept en foirant theron walis
zoumarou of date
[Musique]
oui
noir
new york selon
des mémos
de
[Musique]
votre perception en guerre contre le
terrorisme sait on peut dire c'est une
guerre demande il ya beaucoup de choses
qu'on ne connaissait pas et
l'endroit se demander qu'est ce que ça
veut dire le terrorisme aussi j'ai
grandi aussi en afrique et la guerre de
libération on nous a dit quand il m'a
dit que c'était des services aussi et
qui sont les vrais terroristes qu'est ce
que c'est que le terrorisme est lui
aussi on doit regarder que après la
guerre froide
que 20 des besoins en a toujours besoin
d'un méchant d'un ennemi des quinquas
d'avoir peur
et pour d'abord contre les gens mais
surtout aussi il ya l'aspect économique
que des dépenses immense des budgets
l'hominisation de désarmer et
sous le nom de la guerre contre le
terrorisme on ya beaucoup vous des
questions qu'on se pose
et ça vraiment on peut dire que depuis
que la guerre contre le terrorisme va
commencer à lons étant vraiment le monde
a changé complètement
derrière gestion
[Musique]
de
16,5 mio chf
[Musique]
c'est vraiment la même chose je pense
que on doit tous ne pas accepter ce
qu'on ce qu'on me dit de demander des
questions ne pas faire confiance à ce
qu'on lui dit de ce qu on lit ce qu'on
voit à la fusion mais je pense que les
jeunes il sauve c'est à dire je pense
que la génération sont déjà
s'aperçoit de ça et ne l'a pas par peur
aussi de ne pas de s'éduquer essayer de
chercher des demandes et des questions
et surtout de ne pas avoir peur on doit
avoir du courage
et c'est vraiment à eux inchangés
nous sommes une autre génération
on a posé beaucoup de problèmes mais on
va laisser beaucoup de problèmes pour
pour le jeune et c'est vraiment à eux
c'est dans leurs mains de changer aussi
de d'utiliser la technologie qu'ils ont
d'une façon
intelligente parce que la technologie
l'internet et où l'information qu'ils
ont au bout des doigts ça peut être
utilisé d'une façon négative pour le
contrôler on l'a vu lui aussi sa peut
être
utilisé les trois centres très puissante
pour changer propager dépit du bien à ce
mépris du bien à la technologie c'est ça
exactement merci beaucoup monsieur je
vous avez une très bonne journée à
plusieurs
[Musique]
à partir du moment où on autorise les
opérateurs à faire ce qu'ils veulent sur
le réseau en fait on les autorise à
modifier la société où les autorise à
modifier la façon dont les gens interne
de mieux en mieux il ya de plus en plus
d'opportunités de jupons plus de savoir
et de talent et de plus en plus de
solutions et de plus en plus de capitaux
pour des projets c'est à dire que ce qui
manque à l'heure actuelle
que dans beaucoup de pays ont fait
évoluer le cadre institutionnel pour
incluant la société civile dans le débat
et on est très loin de faire ça en
france
pensez même un peu la terreur d 1,6